Speaker 1: I have a story for you today that
is a story about many things we've been talking
about.
And fundamentally, the story is about conspiracy
theorists moving to Central and South America,
Mexico and Central America, and starting a
kind of conspiracy off the grid communes.
And it's really wild, but it points to a number
of different issues we've talked about.
One is these people rarely believe only one
conspiracy and that's what can make them sound
so dangerous.
Number two, there is almost always anti-Semitism
there.
If you find any real conspiracy believer,
there will almost always be some openly or
implicitly anti-Semitic belief.
And of course, they're completely unhinged.
So let's look at this clip.
This is from Vice News.
Vice News went down to check out these enclaves,
and it speaks for itself.
Speaker 3: The brothers bring potential buyers
to tour the community of about 214 lots.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: Each lot starts at $20,000 plus
the cost of building a house.
About 20% of them have sold.
Speaker 2: People have asked me, you go also,
I like AC.
Can I have AC?
I said, Yes, you can have all the comforts
you want.
You can have the Internet, you can have cable
TV and you're going to have a nice kitchen.
So it's like living in the city but in the
jungle, right?
So we're going to walk through the face to,
okay, so where the lights are available.
Speaker 3: All of the conveniences of modern
society without any of its laws.
Sounds like a utopia, but when all conspiracies
are given equal credence, some dark ideas
can appear.
Speaker 1: This is wild.
Speaker 3: What brings you here today, Joanne?
We have a big mountain demons that are trying
to control our lives.
So let's see what's going on, because we might
have to head to the hills.
Speaker 1: So now here with demons, she might
mean literal or metaphorical demons.
We don't yet know.
But just wait.
Speaker 3: I am worried about the graphene
oxide in the injections.
And I'm worried about the vaccines.
COVID vaccines.
Well, they're not vaccines.
You I will not call them that.
They're injections or injections of graphene
oxide.
When you add graphene oxide into the body
and you're hooking that to the cloud.
This is craziness.
It's just hard for me because so much of what
you're saying, like I've never heard of before,
and it goes against like a lot of the things
that I've been told our true you have been.
Speaker 1: I would even say it more strongly
because when you say you haven't heard of
something, it's easy to say, well, you got
to inform yourself what really it's I there's
been no evidence presented to suggest any
of this is true.
Speaker 3: For so much.
And then you can kind of get.
Into something else, which I accidentally
stumbled upon, which was were there gas chambers
in Nazi Germany?
And there is 6 million people die in Nazi
Germany?
Yes.
Well, that's a great answer, but it's probably
the wrong answer.
But so even people watching have lost relatives
in the Holocaust.
They know people died.
So what you are saying feels like an attack
on them personally?
No, you're putting words in my mouth and words
in their mouth.
What does this have to do with life?
Off grid, living life.
So maybe people can't see the lie in what's
going on with COVID 19.
But there are many books and many, many experts
took apart the gas chamber story 101 different
ways.
What are the rest of you guys think of this?
Speaker 2: There's always going to be a difference
of opinions between people.
This is a normal human trait.
So we should not judge people based on what
they say or they don't say.
Speaker 3: Joanne is welcome.
Speaker 2: Here everybody's way.
Absolutely.
Speaker 3: All of these alternative communities
are brought together by one thing.
They're against the COVID 19 vaccines and
mandates.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: So it's it's very, very scary stuff.
And this is why I tend to agree increasingly
with the conspiracy and cult experts we talk
to who say, yeah, you know, maybe they believe
flat earth stuff or they just don't want the
vaccine personally because they think there's
graphene oxide in it and it'll link you up
to the cloud or whatever.
But there's often really ugly stuff underlying
it exactly as you saw there.
And unfortunately, that is not going to be
someone you can talk sense into